[Music]
I first saw Stanley Kubrick's science
fiction epic 2001 a Space Odyssey in the
summer of that year I can't recall what
instigated this but I remember renting
the VHS from Blockbuster and being
shocked by the G rating needless to say
I wasn't prepared for it
my first watch went about as well as it
could for a thirteen-year-old the
lengthy sequences without sound or
dialogue bored me the purposefully
static images were tedious and the last
15 minutes left me confused to say the
least in the coming years the film
wouldn't leave my mind I tell myself no
you watch that you didn't like it but
that didn't matter
I found myself drawn to it like an
addict to a drug they just can't quit
with the availability of DVD increasing
I got my hands on a copy and with this
viewing I gleaned much more the deeper
themes and the implications Kubrick was
trying to communicate became clearer a
few years later I watched the film a
third time and it finally struck all the
right chords with me 2001 is without a
doubt one of the most revered films ever
made but it isn't without detractors the
most common criticisms regarding the
film are generally similar to mine on
the initial viewing Kubrick's pacing is
glacial the edits are methodical the
frames are painstakingly symmetrical and
the sound design is often so relaxing it
can put you to sleep when 2001 is viewed
through the lens of entertainment it's
understandable that some will find it an
overhyped
or but this film isn't just mere
amusement meant to pass the time it's an
allegory for all of humanity and it's
proved as shockingly accurate warning
for our meddling tendencies publishing a
dissertation on 2001 today feels a tad
unnecessary given that searching the
phrase 2001 a Space Odyssey analysis
Garner's over 1 million search results
fans critics and scholars have been
discussing this film for decades there's
no shortage of information about it on
the web so odds are much of this has
been said already but seeing as this
month is its 50th anniversary and this
is one of my most requested reviews I've
got a lot to say but this will not be an
explained video I assure you there's
plenty of those on this platform already
of course I'll discuss my thoughts on
the meaning of certain sequences but
this isn't meant to be a scene-by-scene
analysis of what every goddamn thing
means because this quote from Roger
Ebert has stuck with me in regards to
this film audiences don't like simple
answers I guess they want the monolith
to stand for something well it does it
stands for a monolith without an
explanation it's the fact that man can't
explain it that makes it interesting
if Kubrick had explained it perhaps by
having some little green men from Mars
lower it into place would that have been
satisfactory does everything need an
explanation some people think so I
wonder how they endure looking at the
Stars yes under the surface 2001 story
could be explained in many different
ways
our evolution our discovery of tools how
we instantly turned that tool into a
weapon how we've become so powerful that
we've lost control of our tools and how
in space we're like infants once more
learning to walk eat and even use the
bathroom in this new environment
Kubrick gave us much to appreciate in
every wondrous frame but that has always
been secondary for me it's really the
feeling I get while watching this film
that outshines everything else 2001 is
the closest experience I've had to
feeling hypnotized Kubrick's editing is
methodical yes but it's really the sound
design the use of richard strauss's also
sprach zarathustra the now iconic
composition that plays at integral parts
or even the breathing sounds in the
silent depths of space
supposedly recorded by Kubrick himself
all put me in a trance from the
beginning of the film the images of a
desolate early African landscape
immediately locked me into a sense of
wonder and awe through a quick series of
scenes we understand that early man is
preyed on and lives in fear before long
the mysterious monolith appears
terrifying them at first before
eventually enticing them not long after
we see one of them
fiddling around with a pile of bones
discovering that it can be used as a
tool
soon enough some of them are walking on
two legs scaring away another group even
killing one of them his tool has become
a weapon he throws it into the air and
perhaps the most famous edit in history
occurs we jump forward drastically in
time observing space travel but what are
we cutting to a spaceship a satellite a
nuclear weapon
opinions vary with even Kubrick himself
never confirming many figures behind the
film's production have said that it is a
nuclear device of some sort
if so Kubrick's cut from man's first
primitive weapon to its most advanced
and deadly is profound
these effects still astonish fifty years
later and similar to what George Lucas
accomplished nine years after Kubrick
they will be timeless forever hell
they're still conspiracy theories
surrounding Kubrick's involvement in
faking the footage of the moon landing
that's got to be the ultimate compliment
for visual effects artists your work is
so good NASA probably called you up to
fabricate the moon landing soon were on
a Jupiter mission with Dave Frank and
Hal 9000 while the story here becomes
more straightforward it's really the
implications Kubrick explores that feel
most unique Hal 9000 for instance tests
Frank while playing chess with him in a
way cheating when Frank fails to realize
this how the sides the crew isn't up to
the task of this mission and takes over
our creations have finally overpowered
us all our knowledge and advancement for
what to have a machine control our lives
how right Kubrick was there has been
much discussion about the final 20
minutes Dave appears to enter a Stargate
or wormhole arriving in a room the room
appears to be a sterile cage of sorts as
if something wishes to observe him in a
series of cuts he gets older before
finally the monolith appears again Dave
extends his hand to it like
Michelangelo's famous painting of Adam
reaching for God while Kubrick was
notoriously tight-lipped he did have
this to say about 2001
on the deepest psychological level the
film's plot symbolizes the search for
God and it finally postulates what is
little less than a scientific definition
of God the film revolves around this
metaphysical conception and the
realistic hardware and the documentary
feelings about everything were necessary
in order to undermine your built-in
resistance to the poetical concept when
Dave is reborn as the Starchild we're
seeing a new dawn an entity that doesn't
need our technological devices to
survive in this uncharted space just as
the film opened with ancient life the
film closes with new life with rich
possibilities ahead of it most people
who sit down in a movie theater have a
wall built around them it's a well
deserved cage of skepticism if it's
their goal to connect emotionally with
these viewers or impart a deeper message
it's the filmmakers job to carefully
break down that wall before their film
ends while not every filmmaker
accomplishes this Kubrick certainly did
with 2001 its warnings to us have been
proven accurate for ever timely and
strikingly relevant still today but
beyond the metaphors its technical
achievement is still aw inspiring truly
2001 is the closest I've come to
experiencing literal hypnotism from a
film that sensation will never be
recreated